SKOOBY-DO MEETS THE "A" TEAM.
>> THAT IS SOMETHING I WOULD
LOVE TO WATCH.
I WOULD LOVE TO SPEND MORE TIME
WITH YOU.
YOU ARE AN INCREDIBLE GUY.
>> WHAT THE HELL DID YOU PUT ME
ON THE SHOW?
>> TO TALK ABOUT YOUR SERIES.
>> WE TALKED FOR A LONG TIME.
>> WE TALKED FOR A LONG TIME OFF
THE CAMERA.
>> THE NEW SHOW, MIKE TYSON
AIRS.
>> DON LEMON.
>> ADULT SWIM.
THANK YOU, MIKE TYSON.
I LOVE YOU.
>> I LOVE YOU TOO.
WE
>>> I'M BACK WITH MIKE TYSON.
HE IS STILL HERE.
>> PUMP THE BOOK, DON.
>> YOU SHOULD BUY THIS BOOK AND
NEXT TIME, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
YOU ON FOR LONGER.
>> SHOW THE BOOK, DON.
SHOW THE BOOK.
>> I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
TOMORROW NIGHT I WILL BE LIVE IN
FERGUSON AS IT GETS CLOSE TO A
GRAND JURY SITUATION.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN?
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
CONVICT HIM?
>> WE WILL FIND OUT.
>> SAY THAT IN THE